un día de reivindicación de derechos
desde méxico hasta chile miles de
personas salieron a las calles de
américa latina' el día internacional de
la eliminación de violencia contra la
mujer
[Música]
es necesaria una política con mayor
presupuesto pero además una política con
una perspectiva feminista entonces
necesitamos participación de las
organizaciones sociales en el control de
sus políticas lima- exigieron justicia
por las víctimas de esterilización
forzada de las que unas 270.000 peruanas
fueron víctimas durante el gobierno de
alberto fujimori una compañía de teatro
recreo un funeral
estamos llevándola al borde este del
dolor que sentimos todas las mujeres por
tan cifras tan altas que han habido
durante este año 132 feminicidios y ya
estamos haciendo tanto por ella como por
todas casi una de cada tres mujeres ha
sufrido abusos en algún momento de su
vida según la onu mujeres denuncia que
durante la pandemia de dos de cada tres
sufrieron alguna forma de violencia que
puede ser física sexual y psicológica
en méxico culpar al presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador por la falta de
acción
siempre estamos marchando no y no
tendría que ser así porque al final la
violencia tiene que erradicarse no
entonces pues estamos viendo que no que
no hay una buena respuesta por parte de
las autoridades por ejemplo cuando se
denuncia
bolivia las marchas también fueron
multitudinarias
[Aplausos]
y estamos hartas de todo lo que sucede
en el país cotidianamente hasta el día
de hoy son 98 feminicidios los que hemos
presenciado en bolivia
en una forma de desafiar los
estereotipos las cholitas escaladoras
alcanzaron la cima del pico más alto de
bolivia llevando un mensaje de
empoderamiento femenino
[Música]